hmm look at this [ __ ] this looked like a
shot damn green-screen to you look at
this ain't no green-screen
so last week if you guys remember I got
her to go to see your ball with me
that's right your boy got game even
though it took me a four years to do it
now now before we go ahead and get
further into the story let's get to know
the girl of my dreams for a bit now what
you all didn't know about it was hanging
out with her it was probably one of the
most hardest things to do on earth now
don't get it twisted it wasn't because I
had feelings for at the time it was
because her parents were strict as hell
and when I say strict
I mean strict the way her father locked
it up you would have thought her
teardrops had the cure to cancer smoosh
it look I remember times I would walk
her home and if I felt the presence of
her father I would go Crouching Tiger
Hidden Korean dolls and ambushes
so because her parents were so strict
the only real way we could communicate
was through late-night phone calls and
to be honest with you at a certain point
those were the things I look forward to
every night and I remember waiting for
her to call because when she did I
always had a stupid grin on my face
here's the thing to me these phone calls
were more than just late-night phone
conversations you know I can't really
speak for her but it was honestly the
only time I got to know we're on a
personal level and you know it's funny
because beyond the way her hands fell
her eyes the way she smiled I think I
started falling in love with the sound
of her voice and as a stupid as it
sounds I wanted to be her reason to
smile so that night I awaited her phone
call and when we picked up we had a
normal conversation we smiled me laughs
become versed but somewhere in between
all that I I just decided to tell her
how I felt about her I told her that
since the moment I met her I had not
been able to get her off my mind and I
had felt this way about her for the
longest time y'all want to know what she
said she said that had this s where the
story gets interesting
look a buggy would you like look but in
all seriousness huh she actually said
that she didn't feel the same she gave
me the classic answer that all girls
gave the guys in high school when they
were too afraid to reject them I gotta
tell you something I'm not gonna lie
what I heard that I wanted to die
just straight up I feel stupid because I
should have never opened up my mouth
because why for one moment with someone
like her feel anything for someone like
me surprisingly enough we actually ended
that conversation on a positive note and
even though I was heartbroken I was
still going to prom with her so now
let's fast-forward to the day of prom
now picking her up from prom was an
amazing experience because I vividly
remember what she was wearing and seeing
her in that dress was probably the most
beautiful thing that I had ever seen you
know I still vividly remember her
looking at me and smiling and as she
walked forward towards me in that dress
she nearly tripped and ate [ __ ] one
thing that I forgot to mention to you
guys was that this girl was clumsy and
held for as long as I've known her I had
seen her trip and fall into a ton of
[ __ ] and even when we would play fight
she was somehow always managed to like
stab me in the eye but when you love
someone you love all their positives and
all their flaws so it actually became a
big part of our friendship so let's fast
forward a bit once again so she and I
graduated high school and we still
remain friends but we had to stop our
late night phone conversation because of
her parents so we continued our
relationship through emails but of
course through the rare moments that we
actually did get to talk on the phone I
converse with her like nothing ever
happened
like we were still really good friends
and I didn't have feelings for anymore
but one day AHA I snapped and I realized
I couldn't do it anymore you know as
pathetic as it sounds I couldn't act
like I was happy around her anymore
I couldn't do it I wasn't being honest
with myself and I had to move on she
told me that she couldn't do it because
we were friends and even though I know
that was a euphemism for she doesn't
really like me I had to hear it flat out
you know the reason why was because I
needed to know indefinitely that there
was not
that could happen between us so I could
accept this and move on with our
friendship so one night I just decided
to go ahead and email her and just come
clean I told her how miserable I had
been the past few months and then I
still had feelings for her so I waited
for her to reply back and when she did
do you know what she responded back with
I can't are you [ __ ] kidding me I
can't I remember being so pissed because
out of all the years of friendship I
asked for one thing and that was a
straight answer and she could not do it
after I just told her about how [ __ ]
stupid I felt that maybe we could be
together when obviously we couldn't all
she had to do was say move on but she
wouldn't do that for me
my god I emailed her back and I asked
her Stan but to my surprise I got a
reply with a phone call she actually
called me to meet a better house when
her parents were gone so we could talk
about this face to face and deal with it
was finally going to tell me in person
to move on and I wasn't sure if I was
scared or happy but I just wanted to get
this over with and hear the verdict so
that day I walked over to her house met
her up and I gotta tell you something
this is where the story gets interesting
I know I know y'all are pissed off is
that another cliff hanger will guess
what y'all been cursing at me for the
past couple weeks so suck it no but in
all seriousness if you guys have been
asking is this a true story yes it is
it's from my perspective of my very very
first love mm-hmm but the series will be
ending soon and it is coming to a
conclusion probably in the next couple
episodes so enjoy that so go to the
website and make sure you guys copy gear
and any kind of question when it comes
to shipping sizing and all the other
stuff will be on the website a lot of
you guys have been messaging me about
payment now yes you can pay without a
PayPal account with just a credit card
but you would use PayPal as a secure
server with the credit card that you use
just follow the instruction there'll be
a link that says if you don't have a
PayPal account click that and allow you
to use PayPal on a temporary basis with
your credit card so you have a secure
server so yes these shirts are a
promotional price and on top of that
they're only out for a limited time for
limb
did quantities and of course in the next
week or two we will be coming out within
a couple of more designs thank you guys
for all your love support and I will see
you all next week
my friends Ram Oh almost did the fingers
again bring back the guns put them back
in the holster peace out thank you the
orphans they love you in space
Uribe